boa noite
olha convidaram aqui o cartunista e
processo oposto é falarmos de cartum
naturalmente né
cartum um quarto nesta palavra e se essa
coisa de bola a gente tem tão pouca
tradição tem pouco conhecimento época
pouco uso aqui na nossa história nosso
país
convém temos visto agora estou focado no
tempo
na verdade 173 anos e euna no sítio na
altura e na altura também o cartão não é
associado ao desânimo um humorístico
hosani satírico tem outras conotações
mas porque cartuchos termo em inglês
porque que não há nenhum termo em
português
de fato não há não há nenhum equivalente
em português que defina aquele desânimo
turístico satírico e fomos buscar o
termo em inglês cartune que
inclusivamente muitos deles não sabendo
que minha palavra cantor em francês
temos a palavra schaars significa carga
mas o francês não é não é português é
talvez a gente adaptarem chamamos carga
o mário sérgio dar uma carga espalhada
faria um caminho mais quente deve ser
cartões seria cargo né algum sentido
isso
mas então quando nunca na história o
total está em 173 anos em 1840 1840 de
uma revista e é um hábito que já vem da
idade média os artistas pintores e
principalmente os pintores era muito
comum e como ainda é hoje é a gente
fazer o design final fazer um esboço na
quinta as boas são gráficos
eu faço o papel na altura faziam em
cartão cartão carta ao mesmo tempo
papelão para fazer os seus bons e do
hábito de idade média do latim o latim
cartão é cartoné o latim o império
romano expandiu-se
não sou o canal da mancha e continuou
indo até o quarto negócio virou cartum e
pronto mas ainda a tensão ainda não com
a especificidade de definir o desenho
humorístico era apenas para fazer o
tráfico
acho que fazer o design final que
acontece na altura a realeza do da
inglaterra
os ingleses queriam procurar o palácio
do oeste mista da comissão aquilo que
fizeram promoveram um concurso entre os
artistas para apresentarem propostas
para fazer é a duração do estágio das
moradas das paredes e os vídeos fizeram
os seus cartuchos né
como propostas para parar o coração
os que não foram aprovados naturalmente
nem todo mundo vai ser aprovado
fizeram uma exposição em geral piada uma
paródia do sobre o evento e fazer uma
exposição com os danos desenhados em
cartum em cartoné foi um sucesso imenso
e é a partir daí o termo popularizou se
havia uma vista na altura uma vez em
quanto à vista
pronto é esta a revista país
esta revista é vista do modo mais antiga
do mundo perde se um século atrás da
ponte já publicava na altura desenhos
humorísticos e não tinham ter um cartoon
e foram eles os responsáveis por para
disseminação do tema um cartoon pelo
mundo
a curiosidade só várias paredes de
imagens da da vista não
a curiosidade é que sendo uma visita tão
antiga ela durou até os anos 90
eis aqui é que uma versão bem mais
moderna da vez não morreu várias vezes
ressuscitou outras tantas voltou a
mulher voltou a se irritar e morreu três
anos devendo mesmo assim a obra é uma
obra grande a ser tida em conta
e nessa altura ficaram famosos
caricaturistas cartunistas que deram
grande impulso ao cartão da autora e
senhora de arlit ficou conhecido como um
dos grandes expoentes máximos que deu
uma contribuição imensa para
divulgação do cartão pelo mundo e se
minha hora está no oeste e outro é
senhor james tirei é considerado o pai
do cartoon político
se calhar é meu pai assim eu não sei o
que deu também um grande contributo à
difusão do cartão político é pelo mundo
em 1805 ainda em 1905 ela fez design
esse boneco que significa que satiriza
os tempos das guerras napoleônicas estão
napoleão e o império britânico a dividir
o bolo
o globo do mundo sobre as suas áreas de
influência é um dos grandes são design
icônico do quarto mundial e ainda existe
está no museu de nova york o museu da
imprensa em nova york onde a gestão de
mais veneradas e espalharam os seus
gêmeos e eu estivesse vivo e não
estivesse vivo é perceber que não
souberam grande cartunista como era um
grande bruxo né porque as coisas não
mudaram muito a nível daquilo que é a
divisão do bolo do do mundo que é hoje
né não
isto agora pra pra avançar para dizer
que nessa altura portanto o cartoon
expandiu se para disputar pelo pelo
mundo
vou pra imprensa ou por jornais roupas
revistas
vou para os festivais
vou pra escolas como já é objeto de
estudo os prémios né e ainda hoje o
grande prémio internacional de
jornalismo constam do jornalismo
atribuído a quem são atribuídos prémios
costa o karton como por exemplo o prêmio
pulitzer
nos estados unidos todos os anos eles
premium melhor cartunista americano
o prêmio da sociedade internacional de
jornalistas premeiam todos os anos os
meus cartões ea uma série em centenas
que vai ficar tão pelo mundo fora
acho que é a parte tivemos a mais blur
iosa do cartucho fato é que onde ela se
torna um ramo do jornalismo com com
identidade própria com pernas para andar
e durante esse tempo curto o consagrou
é muitos autores consagrou é e
personagens e principalmente estamos a
falar dos custos dos consagrados os mais
velhos e os mais novos que já não
conhecem como eu disse no princípio nós
não temos aqui uma grande tradição de
leitura dos cartões os hábitos de
leitura são aquelas que a gente conhece
os livros à venda é aquilo que a gente
sabe mas convém investigar pesquisar a
mafalda do autor argentino chamado quino
um dos ícones mundiais do cartoon
celebrado em quase toda a américa latina
no mundo hispânico no mundo da língua
portuguesa pouco de dentro entre o
inglês não gostar crônico mas é um dos
ícones mundiais do cartoon os pinots nos
estados unidos foi um dos primeiros foi
um elmo dos veículos principais do
estudo do cartão americano deixar os
chutes no piche ano e toda aquela
companhia coisas maravilhosas a nível da
da crítica almada das relações humanas
dos hábitos e costumes das relações
entre as pessoas entre as crianças é uma
coisa maravilhosa
na mesma linha e mais recente o calvino
em outros também fez um papel
extraordinário considerado vai por
várias vezes o melhor prato americano
nos últimos 20 a 30 anos
eu já passou de desenhar e uma das
características deste autor do golo o
telefone é que eu não quis me acham das
suas personagens nem camisola em bonecos
nem coisinhas que sairá nada disse
já não dá entrevistas não aparece um
indivíduo com todo o sucesso que fez um
enorme poder de seminário da pessoa e
assim e do dodô por exemplo doou disney
numa outra vertente do cartoon mais na
vertente entretenimento disney e
construiu aquele império aquela boneca
cada toda a gente conhece até hoje 11
mais uma das maiores empresas do mundo
a ouvirem productions o make um pó tonal
do tio patinhas de pateta no brasil é
uma das mais animadas no brasil temos eu
também na escolinha do budismo temos o
maurício de sousa que faz a turma da
mônica em toda a bancada que vem por
trás da vida da turma da mônica e isso
naturalmente para dizer que a vertente
do quarto não é o cartoon editorial que
o cartoon que acompanha e satiriza a
realidade do dia-a-dia social e político
ea um quarto mas neri kufa somou
genérico sobre infrações das pessoas o
gordo eo magro feio bonitas do que
estamos a falar e do daquilo que estamos
a referir exatamente o que se torna no
ramo do jornalismo é o cartoon editorial
que é mais ou menos a linha que eu sigo
de inspiração satírica é eu trouxe uma
casa lá porque opera com muitas coisas
que uma das coisas que não sei me bem
fazer é falar
inspirada no caso nós políticos e também
quando falava se aplicavam então esses
políticos e inspiram muito e portanto
também trouxe uma cábula fazer o que
voltarmos ao ponto de partida a bola que
nós temos a nível do cartum em angola
temos pouca coisa
temos uma história relativamente antes
do da independência temos alguns nomes é
o nome fantasia da liga este é o zé da
filha que nos anos 70 anos 30
eu próprio era português em angola e da
experiência eu tinha um quartel e não
consegue criar um personagem chamado zé
da fisga e fazia umas piadas locais da
experiência que eu devia que fazia
sucesso na altura foi o personagem mais
sucesso teve na altura dos anos 30
chamados é da filha porque andava sempre
com uma franja que vai ficar aqui atrás
do bolso havia outros autores
o rico fazia um cartoon bem bem
contundentes acerca dos problemas da
altura anos tem agora como por exemplo
buracos nas estradas efeitos das chuvas
e coisas que a gente pensa que só tem
hoje já tinha na altura eu era muito
forte
nesse sentido este é o manoel ribeiro
angolano também trabalhavam junto com o
homem que fazia da filha e também teve
alguma expressão na altura os anos 70 e
também já depois da independência que
fazia lacraus kikas procurou o semanário
suplemento tendo em que eles publicaram
as chamadas lacrau e daí até cáustica
havia também uma série de de piadas mais
ou menos contundente sobre sobre a
realidade da altura
neste caso o porteiro é um personagem já
podem dependência foi publicado no
semanário local e saía empréstimo pela
pelas máquinas do jornal de angola muito
maior empresa desse passagem
eu tentei conseguir a de pesquisar num
caso sobre os autores da altura não
conseguir perceber que saber quem é esse
tal touro o v costa ela assinava costa o
caso tem alguma piada
o marimbondo também do rio ganhará
chance se conhece não está pra cá foi o
mesmo a autora que o fecho uma banda
desenhada ficou também conhecida e foi
publicada pelo jornal de angola sobre 27
de maio do golpe estado de 7 mais
ambicioso e tamanhos ganharam mais
conhecido da altura dos anos 30 que saiu
publicado na revista novembro e depois
dessa altura não temos nada todo o
período dos anos da década de 80
tivemos um grande vazio e seus autores o
parceiro deixaram publicadas gremistas
acabaram e não publicaram livros enfim
uma tristeza anos 80 foi uma seca e nos
anos 90 pronto apareceu esse senhor aqui
que o embaixador
bom na altura eu estava integrado num
grupo de maluquinhos da banda desenhada
nos humildes todas as 78 anos e eram
liderados pelo nosso mestre que abrange
infelizmente já falecido
ela era o nosso o nosso mentor e
conseguimos de fato fazer algumas coisas
que foram os primeiros na verdade não
havia mais nada antes disso nós
conseguimos que há ali um núcleo muito
interessante de jovens muito engajados
de muito muito dedicados à causa da
banda desenhada e evitar muito fato pela
pela pelas mãos do anime vieira na
altura que era que era secretário geral
da união de escritores publicamos três
primeiros álbuns de banda desenhada
nesse mesmo ano nós estamos começando
também a colaborar com o jornal de
angola a nível do quarto no eu eo alex
silva que infelizmente também na praça
nunca mais nunca mais dinheiro nos
ensinado voltar aos relvados ou não
falar que sim e lançarmos xi também duas
coletâneas de cartões nesta altura
àquela altura numa altura muito muito
boa muito difícil porque estava
acontecendo uma série de coisas no país
é o processo do país estava em curso é o
regime tenha passado do partido o único
por ter problema multipartidário o
jornal de angola tinha spanking aberto
ao contraditório e à opinião de 7 de
abril também ao quarto nós aproveitarmos
essa abertura e o cartoon espantou a
partir daí com todos o sucesso que fez
que eu sei que muita gente que cortava e
fazia coleções é certa uma kiko é ganhou
o o benefício ligamos dessa abertura
bom então é nessa altura com a
publicação dos cartões no jornal de
angola durante tudo desde 1990 em diante
foi de fato um período muito muito bom
muito positivo
tivemos um que vemos um sucesso muito
grande as pessoas gostavam e foi um
grande incentivo para nós até 1994
em 1994 o brasil se encontra aqui o
boneco bom por causa deste cartum em
o diretor do jogo angola foi exonerado
foi chutado e eu o cartunista também por
arrasto também foi daí que desde 94 até
hoje nunca mais tenha publicado no
jornal da globo não por minha vontade
naturalmente foi um cartoon que depois
mais tarde foi leiloado nós levamos diz
carton por 600 dólares não me lembro que
depois do e há um projeto para crianças
necessitadas que o falso manuel denise
estava organizado e e foi de facto o
início da travessia no deserto né
depois dessa altura nunca mais se ouviu
falar do capitão teremos aqui um grande
ato na mídia que deixou de aparecer para
o jogo na hora do fato como único diário
do país é o único de arte país é o
principal veículo de distribuição de
divulgação do cartoon e deixarmos de ter
nos anos de 2000 eu repassei repasse e
eu em particular 2008 atenção em 2008 e
ultimamente como cadinho mais de de
freqüência graças também à angola e as
redes sociais
bom mas então o que é que há o que há de
especial no cartão sim aqui até falta
alguma coisa especial no quarto pra mim
eu acho e estou convicto disso o cartão
é uma forma muito interessante acho que
a palavra é essa é muito interessante da
expressão de opinião e de intervenção
acho acho que dentro do único única peça
é uma única peça que combina três
valências
o design combina a crítica combina humor
e ficaria também a criatividade
se não tiver essas três quatro valências
combinadas num cartoon é pá não é cartum
né
outra coisa qualquer é uma ilustração
um engenho eu qualquer coisa que pudesse
ela está em que ele tem saído nos lagoa
é uma gata
então não não houver essa combinação de
luz - debatemos outra coisa qualquer
e de facto tem que ter esse condimento
não têm interesse nessa juntamento com
coisas para para que esse resultado
resultou num cartoon do facto
profissional e pensado o tal que se
enquadra na linha do ramo do jornalismo
e por falar em jornalismo eu fui
entrevistado em tempos uma jornalista
portuguesa continuam no local
na introdução da entrevista disse de
chover o que eu era um opositor do
regime de seu pai quando via que o
opositor do regime
mas se sou assim né é assustador uma
coisa é uma coisa grave com muita
responsabilidade
eu sou um cartunista né e faço aquilo
que é suposto o cartunista fazer que
sakineh
essa turma não é mais nada é aquele dado
é aquilo que eu vejo aquilo que eu sinto
que eu sinto desculpem e é tudo tem que
ser feito né
portanto se isso combina com algum tipo
de oposição algum tipo de ativismo é
para que seja também no nome é não me
assusta nada acho que todos nós devemos
ser ativistas
devemos ser opositores do causas não é
de comer causas justas causas boas né
depois acho que nos preocupa é que nos
tocam né por aí
portanto eu não me preocupa nada em ser
ativista mas antes de mais nada acho que
vou ser sincero com aquilo que é a tocar
tornasse uma nada
e nessa onda há muita gente que estava a
falar ea a falar dos elogios que não
fazê las em um livro é uma coletânea
pouco tempo
e são muitos os parabéns e elogios pela
coragem pela coragem e pela coragem
quando eu estava aqui em época de um ano
depois de ouvir uma oferta já não sei se
sou corajoso
é eu sei se eu fosse cartunista em
portugal na no brasileiro ou na áfrica
do sul
eu não teria coragem de coisa nenhuma né
seria mais um dos cartunistas estão lá e
todos os dias se utilizam a classe
política dos respectivos países
então por que aqui chamada bancada do
corajoso não vou responder ao responder
a vocês a gazeta sobre a resposta mas
isto e métodos para a pasta da crítica e
pela liberdade de expressão é da
liberdade de expressão diz que se trata
aqui carton é é está no centro está no
epicentro da liberdade de expressão e da
crítica à crítica é necessária não a
sociedade nenhuma que se faça e se faça
sem crítica e é necessário sempre
criticar exercitem sempre vou sempre
crítico o sentido autocrítica e também
foi bem lembrado aqui ontem a desde é
necessário fazer isso e não é
absolutamente normal que nos impeçam de
fazer se no decorrer desse processo
desse exercício da crítica estejam a
fazer qualquer possibilidade e de forma
justa se adicionarem gindungo zinho do
bom humor
então é isso será prefeito e poderá dar
um bom quarto no obrigado né